ん
ng
えーみなさんこんにちは
本日私が皆さんと共有したいこと
それは
嫌いが自分を拡張するということです
私はこの嫌いに向き合うことで世界観が
広がりより人生を楽しめるようになりまし
た
人生は一度キーです
嫌いで自分を拡張しましょう
言ってしまうとちょっと変な言い方に行き
超えるかもしれませんが本日はそういう話
ができればと思いますよろしくお願いし
ます
私の説明ですね私はシンプルに言うとべた
がけだ標準語で言うと普通が嫌いな人間
でした
個性こそ正義と信じるちょっと厄介な人間
で物事の見方がある意味非常に狭かった
人間です
で少し自分の青年期少年期の時代の説明し
ますテーマはこだわりでした
いとこ同士だった両親が結婚して母は
優しくて父親はサラリーマンをしながらの
評論家でした私は議論あふれの中で育ち
ました
そんな環境でしたんで
例えば当時ゲームとか漫画とか
そのブームがあったんですけどそんな
ブームにはあんまり興味を示さず
には会員ている少年です
その少年が野球に出会ってからは野球三昧
の日々
将来の夢はこだわりの大リーグで4番を
打つこともバットばっかり降っていました
そこはまぁ成長挫折こう繰り返して言って
大学に少し入る前ぐらいですかねロー
new 生ぐらいのときに自分の個性
マートこだわり
そういうものを表現したいと感じました
で大学に入ってから
は自主映画制作に没頭しました
まあそれこそ今度し超初心者なんですけど
方に何かハマりたくないみたいな感じで
パッチを独学で
こだわりの柵に続けました
ずっと作り続けた結果
メディアから少し取り上げられたいだと
学校この表彰されたいとかそこそこ評価い
たんですね
それで
私はもうこんな天狗になって伏せ匂いと
いう感じ
で
超おとがっていました
まあもうこだわりがも激しいので周りから
するとも厄介な人間だったと思います
その時にとある衝撃がありましてそれで
自分を拡張しようと思うようになりました
じゃあその拡張するとき視野を広げようと
そう思ったんですね
でもずっとやってた映画の世界からも離れ
て
報道情報雑誌テレビ業界を渡り歩いて現在
はソフトウェア開発のプロダクト
マネージャーという職に就いています
狭かった私がそういう食5
その本題です衝撃の話です
その衝撃の話は
アイドルのライブでしたアイドルのライブ
で体感した衝撃でした
当時の私は例えば見る映画はあっ後
ヨーロッパの前映画とか聴く音楽は
インディーズとかオルタナティブとか
ちょっとまあ
変わった音楽
そんな人間だったのでメジャーシーンの
ショー2だったアイドルっていうのは全然
興味がなく
さらにそのアイドルを追っかけるファンの
方々にはちょっと嫌悪感すらありました
自分持ってるのとか人生それでいいの
私自身がこう自己発信型の人間だと思って
たのでそういう思いを持っていました
そんな自分が勢いとノリだけでその当時の
映画研究を数人でですね会ライブ会場に
突入したわけです
その瞬間
行くやー
ua
9回以上が圧倒的で京都ものすごい一体感
が僕1階丸きたんですね
そのうねりすごいで僕は風以降ファーの木
帰ったんです
と幸福に満ちた高満面の笑みでがむしゃら
で一生懸命に綱
アイドルを応援する姿それが僕は本当心が
増えました
でその一生懸命な姿にも嫉妬感すら覚え
ました
側線のその姿がめちゃくちゃかっこええ
なあと思ったんですね
ライブ終わってから
1人こう家に帰って振り返ったんですね
本当に衝撃というのは反マリがあつって
られたかっていう
で私を守ったですねやっぱり
今までこう普通と思ってたこと2掛け愛と
思っているそのも斜めから見ているこの
自分
それがその自分こそはカッコ悪いな固定
観念のかため頭ガチガチです
学校ある
で私はある行動に出ます自分のこの既成
概念もまあ取っ払って
アイドルの継承したんですね
な家だあるあの衝撃は3
そこにはすごいものがありました戦略努力
歌曲プロモーションそれ落球と
プロフェッショナのがもう詰まってたん
ですね
で
好きなものから
そこから得ることもできない学びというの
を感じました
嫌いなものから学んだみたいな
で嫌いの中には何か何かがあるんじゃない
かな
思い出したんですねそれで
呪文自答しました
まずちょっと嫌いや苦手を書き出して
みようと思ったんですねそれで出来上がっ
たのが
嫌いなものリスト
でまぁこの嫌いなのリストっていうのは
今まで毛嫌いしたものとか色眼鏡で見て来
パリなとかそれを持ったものをリスト化し
て嫌いを可視化する
それで
そのかしかしさも実際に体感してみると
それが嫌いなものリストそう
私はこれをゆっくりと継続してやっていき
ましたん
そうすることで私自身は
少しずつ口を拡張していくっていうのを
感じていくわけです
ここで少しその例をご紹介しようと思い
ますこれまあ嫌いは多分皆さんと僕とでは
誰も違うと思いますので個人差あると思い
ますがあしからず
一つ目
韓流撮ろう
これも見た目この学校いい男と可愛い女が
出てきてメロドラマな主婦麦見ないな僕
自身そのやっぱり術
肌みたいな感じだったんでこうダートで
ちゃうやろうと
見てみました
おこわ寄付歯ブラシん
もうねぇ
泣きまくりました
実際この構成神獣廟所ものすごく良く出来
てるんでね
逆に総合芸術も塊やどうて今やなと思い
ます
釣り
いうとなんかも時間のない人間でしたので
この時間を粉を使う時間のある人虫歯の書
趣味なんかなと
なんかも時間の浪費数だけ
でまぁそんな釣った魚おいしいわけない
だろうと思ってたんですけど入ってみまし
た
超気持ちですー
海太陽空
まあ当たり前なんですけどそこでも脳が第
1回方ですね
そこでしか考えられへんことっていうのは
言ってオイルはきました
でねー
釣った魚が超美味しいんですよ
こんなちっちゃへ魚でもねやいって食べた
ツクシがビックリしますよ
3つ目かき揚げ
こういう多分写真前ですけど見た目ねその
美しくないで
ごちゃまぜの味これ何の味なんだろう
みたいな
あとマー油の臭いは強烈です
これね実際にもう1回食べてみたと
イメージでこれね食のハーモンヤーナム逆
に変わりますこのがごちゃ混ぜの感じが逆
にこれがスゴそれこそ判明なんじゃないか
な
でここで思ったのが菜食を食べたイメージ
では最初の高所兄のイメージっていうのを
歌がないといけないなというとこれ食べ物
なんで検証は続けていくかなと思ってい
ます
4つね富士
東山
まあ先間の時間の使い方もそうですけど
その山に登る価値ってねえって思ってます
あとは日本人として一度は一時みたいな
まぁよく言われますけど別に行かなくても
別の俺日本人だしみたいな
ですよね
写真とか動画もいっぱいあるんでそれを見
ててもちろんリアルとは違うというのは
わかるんですけど
まあ
でも登ってみました
ご来光3でございます
めっちゃめっちゃ美しいこれね最初に
ちょっととったんですけど
もうねこれ言葉では言い表せないですもう
のすごいも人生観も大回転というか
ものすごい
もう感動感動言い過ぎですよほんとにね
言葉 dns でこの体験をしてからは逆
に小回りには日本人としていか言うとかな
版読んだなスレ言うようになっちゃって
ます
オリックスバファローズつ
もともともか近鉄バファローズっていう
球団のねファンでそれで
あ
なくなりまして消滅しましてそこらの近鉄
ロスということでうつ病になっている家族
もうつ病でまあ大変だったんですけど
それでオリックス菊と頑張るや神戸では
神戸のイメージでパパのでついたら大阪の
イメージなんか違和感あっ
で大近日はね某級打線いて参らせて元幹部
連れ出せオリックスあなんか上品な
イメージしますよね
なんでー
まあまあ
ただ今ではオリックスしか方
すごいですね
先日日本シリーズありました最初泉北まあ
のほっともっとで頭で見てました娘と一緒
もね負け方も勝ち方もドラマティックです
ね
ここは話し出すとちょっと23集が欲しい
んですけど
あの
それこそマーケティングも素晴らしいです
で後イケメンがもうイケメンだだけこれ
もっと女性の方一度ねオリックスの選手み
てくださいケビンがめちゃくちゃ多いで
映像もかっこよかったりグッズが良かっ
たりもう年
ものすごくいい球団
で何よりこのオリックスバファローズと
いう共通言語が家族にできた子で一致団結
できるようになります
ぼくたちの家族
今本当に一生の存在になったなと
持っています
まあこれはあの相手またも違うと思うん
ですがあの皆さんとは
ドラマ僕にとっては
イノベーション連続でした
この嫌いなものリストというのは嫌いを
克服するもんではないんですね
嫌いに苦手なものに挑戦するダイブする
そして新しい世界を見るというあぐ
れっしゅな行為です
でもちろんなんですけども
全部が全部好きになるわけじゃないですね
嫌いなものももちろんあります嫌いなまま
の物語
ただなぜ嫌いなのかっていうのを検証して
それか深くまだ中も知ることができます
なのでマイナーすぐ沿ってないんですね
プラス要素
ここ重要なポイントなんですけどこれは
変化ではなくてやはり拡張です
結局自分の法律って変わらないんですね
年齢的な部分も含めてですけど
シェアが広がって個性がメイクアップ
カープする自分の改造考えが高まる
イメージです
とまぁその試合が広がって物事を決めつけ
なくなった時に人とのコミュニケーション
というのも少し拡張しました
例えば何かこの人苦手かもと思ったとき
ただその人のダックグラウンドを想像
できるようなあったんですね
なーんと色であるやろが結果
納谷めちゃめちゃ一酸化とも言えることが
増えました
理解力は向上したんです
逆に
なんかおり嫌われてるかもと思ったとき
ちょっとずつ自分を説明しようって
その力が自分の中でできてきました
本当に一歩引いた
ちょっとずつこう近づいていけるような
コンビ系でしょ
で私は今
ソフトウェア開発のプロダクト
マネージャーという
食についててこの職業っていうのは
ざっくり言ってしまうといろんなこう
ところですね例えばユーザーもそうですし
営業さんも
サポートももちろん開発者そういう
いろんな人の子の意見っていうものを
やりとりして整理してまとめて責任を持っ
てプロダクトアウトをするという仕事です
広い視野とコミュニケーションはどこが
非常に必要な仕事なんですけどあの狭かっ
た私ですねが
そういう職業に今ついています
もちろんで好きなものに囲まの人生って
もちろん気持ち嬉しいと思うんですよ
ただ私はこの嫌いなものリストに
チャレンジすることによって
狭かった自分が
少しずつ広くなっていきます
でここで皆さんに言いたいのが
一同自分を疑ってみませんか
あえて嫌いへダイブしていませんか
そうすると人生が動き出すかも知れませ
再び動き出すというイメージに近いです
あと人生最大の出会いがあるかも知れませ
最後にもう一度だけ
いわしてください
嫌いで自分を拡張しましょう
ということで本日まあこうやって話をさせ
ていただきましたが私自身この自分の考え
というのはこんな大勢の皆さんの前でハウ
スっていうのはもうにがって嫌いでした
ただ
これでチャレンジしてみて
また自分が1つ拡張できたなと
持っています
本日はありがとうございました
[拍手]